remember that the david pakman show is a
dependent on folks who decide to get
memberships on my website you can sign
up at joinpackman.com we do an extra
show every day for our members we also
offer commercial free audio and video
streams of the show for our members
and when we do viewer town halls like we
did a few weeks ago members get a
separate priority line to talk to me
and lots of other great little perks so
sign up at joinpackman.com you can use
the new coupon code
wow 22
to get a significant discount at
joinpakman.com
let's look at some interesting posts
from this morning on the david pakman
show subreddit the david pakman show
subreddit can be found at
davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t
more than 33 000 of our viewers and
listeners have subscribed there uh first
post is concerns over right wing friends
this is an interesting topic
uh user app-man
writes hey everyone as the title implies
i have a bit of a serious issue growing
up i had a conservative phase i was only
like 16 and was pulled in by the 2016
wave of conservatism on youtube and
social media i ended up making some
friends at this time with similar
interests we were pretty much your
standard i'm a classical liberal type
watched ben shapiro debates maybe some
paul joseph watson a lot of stephen
crowder
over time i drifted away and became a
lot more liberal these friends however
did the opposite they're extremely right
wing they think covet is a left-wing
power grab which is annoying
uh considering i've worked on a coveted
unit since april and see it firsthand
trump actually won the election armed
insurrection is justified and i fear
they're even beginning to dabble in
white nationalism our talks have become
noticeably more tense all they do is
post guns on their instagrams and spam
their stories with far-right propaganda
is there any hope of helping them
should i just cut them off if i was able
to drift liberal could i manage to help
them as well i appreciate the advice i
mean listen this is a really i get calls
like this all the time from people this
is a really personal thing
i don't think there's any issue with
having friends with diverse political
opinions i have friends with diverse
political opinions that include you know
kind of casual center-right republicans
mostly focused on tax and regulation
issues people who are sort of outside of
the traditional political space but are
just culturally very liberal or
conservative but i don't have any
friends that are outrageous maga
lunatics and white nationalists and all
these different things because that is
so at odds with what i believe those
views often rife with anti-semitism and
xenophobia and all these things there's
no way for me to put that aside and just
talk about yesterday's basketball game
there's a sort of line and that line is
different for everybody the question
about bringing them to the left
that's a different question altogether
and it really comes down to
how much work are you willing to put in
when we talk about deprogramming and
de-radicalizing people we're talking
about something that can take months of
concerted effort if not longer as i've
said before i think the most
kind of least the least confrontational
way to approach this is to just
regularly ask
basic probing questions about
how did you come to believe that how did
you come to believe that kind of a soft
socratic method of questioning but it's
a very personal thing what you are
willing to sort of endure
in terms of getting to that point of
having a shot at disabusing them of
these beliefs but let us know how it
goes another post i spotted user philo
posted an article about turning point
usa
building the next generation of
conservative influencers influencer
first
conservative second i have talked for
years
about how the right is willing to lose
money
on individual projects like throwing
tons of cash at these in these
organizations that program young right
wingers to go out and spread the message
so to speak
because they see it as a bigger
investment in the longer term
the right has a lot of views including
on abortion gay marriage taxes health
care where if you just ask questions in
an unbiased way you see that the country
continues to move to the left to the
left to the left but what is the right
doing to continue winning elections and
controlling the narrative
they are just dumping cash
into training up
advocates for their perspectives right
out of college and we on the left should
be very worried about it
i have conversations all the time
with
wealthy ish and very wealthy center
people and actual progressives as well
and they say how can i deploy my
resources and i say you know if you
really
want to make a difference
you've got to fund left-wing media
and create organizations equivalent to
what the right has to get people to
become advocates when they come out of
college because the right has the ground
game figured out and they'll sometimes
say well what about george soros you
know often is what's mentioned soros is
operating on a very different level
soros is not doing what the right is
doing with groups like turning point usa
and others so without a doubt
if the left
really wants
to
control that space
and actually
work to make the country's
uh sort of sort of
public political orientation
match that of what people are privately
saying are their views because remember
our elected officials are way to the
right of where the country is
we've got to fight them the way that
they fight which is dumping a ton of
cash
into these organizations turning point
usa it's a vile organization but they
they are doing exactly what the left
fails to do
last post was and i got a ton of these
anybody know what's up with the
subscriber feed on the website
i thought david was on vacation and i
wasn't paying attention but there's
there are new segments on youtube and
i'm not finding the content on the
website it is 2022 so you must of a
message to all members with peace and
love
you have to go to member content 2022
to find this year's shows 2021 is over i
know a lot of people miss this but the
content is there we are back
join the discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit